le début d'une guerre juridique entre
bruxelles et astrazeneca après plusieurs
mois de rapports tendus entre les deux
parties la patience des 27 états membres
a atteint ses limites
ce lundi la commission européenne a
annoncé lancer une action en justice
contre le laboratoire suédo britannique
elle pointe du doigt un non respect des
contrats de livraisons des précieuses
dose de sérum la commission a entamé
vendredi dernier une action en justice
contre la société astrazeneca pour
violation du contrat d'achat anticipé
la raison de cette action et que les
termes du contrat ou certains des termes
du contrat n'ont pas été respectées et
le groupe n'a pas été en mesure de
proposer une stratégie fiable pour
assurer la livraison des doses dans les
délais ce qui nous importe dans ce cas
c'est que nous voulons nous assurer
qu'il y ait une livraison rapide d'un
nombre suffisant de doses auxquelles les
citoyens européens en droit et qui ont
été promises sur la base du contrat oft
il faut dire que seule la livraison d'un
quart des 120 millions de doses promises
au premier trimestre par le groupe
pharmaceutique a été assurée et le bilan
du deuxième trimestre devrait également
être largement insuffisant astrazeneca
s'est de son côté justifié et affirme
avoir je cite complètement respecter les
contrats jugeant ces poursuites
judiciaires infondées
les vaccins sont difficiles à fabriquer
comme l'ont montré les problèmes
rencontrés par plusieurs groupes en
europe et dans le monde
nous faisons des progrès pour relever
les défis techniques et notre production
s'améliore un litige autour duquel les
deux parties semblent d'ores et déjà
perdante centre les retards accumulés de
l'europe dans sa stratégie vaccinale et
l'image une fois de plus écornée du
groupe astrazeneca